good afternoon my name is dan lew cash
and the Senior Program Officer with
ready to go with the Institute of Museum
and Library Services glad to be here a
couple notes I made before I get into my
presentation just listening to the
projects listening to some of the
projects and the activities and the
themes that people were talking about we
I think it ties in very well with many
of the activities that we do at IMLS a
couple people mentioned talking about
museums have stuff and they want content
trying to match content and act and have
people have access to that I'll move
forward here connect people to
information ideas that's our sort of our
new mission statement I'll just mention
a couple of projects we're doing that
word with the Minneapolis Institute of
Art and the Walker Art Center they have
a very popular website called Arts
connected and we've just funded that
website to do two primary things one
make it open source so everybody can get
to it and then one of the things that in
their focus group was education and
teachers teachers loved having the
resources but they wanted to manage the
resources themselves they want to take
this painting and maybe this video
conversation of the artist about that
painting and these paintings and create
their own lessons plans to meet their
own their state standards where a lot of
times museums we're creating putting the
content up and then creating the lesson
plan and curricula for them so this art
connected website we're funding so
teachers can gather their own resources
i think that ties in with a lot of what
we've heard here also i think our
friends at michigan state have a current
project with some video conferencing
i'll know if it's out of your officer in
another office video conferencing with
schools connecting house tues can learn
through video conferencing I think that
ties in very nicely another project
we're doing is down at George Mason in
their new media center they've take
they've working with the Smithsonian may
have taken six objects of national
prominence for example Thomas
Jefferson's desk the shorthand a low for
Cesar Chavez and the lunch counter at
Woolworth's are three of the first three
coming out they've created a lesson plan
around those particular objects and then
have created
information and text so local historic
sites can login use that national object
and then create a website in a lesson
plan they give them the instructions to
do that and incorporate that national
object with their local history and then
they're also doing online I think
through both website transmission video
conferencing with specific historians
from the Smithsonian talking about those
particular objects and then the historic
site is able to create their own lesson
plans with the local schools that tie
into their local history so I think
those are some projects in some areas
where we were interested in so i think
we're IMLS is really on the same
wavelength of everybody here of trying
to get that excess trying the divisional
digital vibes not just who has computers
and who doesn't have computers the type
of access and the ability to use that I
think all these projects sort of tie
that it and that's what everyone is
talking about here in this particular
conference of trying to talk tie all
that information together so everybody
in 122,000 libraries and who uses
seventeen thousand five hundred thousand
museums if you believe all those numbers
to be accurate occur and we do grant
making convening research our primary
eligible applicants are museums
libraries and on certain programs
Institutes of higher education are
eligible to apply and I'll touch on that
in a minute I've provided a list of all
our programs but I'm just going to focus
on one program for museums and which is
our museum for America only museums are
eligible for this program but the goal
of this program is to fund something
that's specific to that institutions
strategic plan or long-range goal a lot
of times it is these digital video type
projects so here's an opportunity you
want to work with the museum engaged and
remind them of this museums for america
program and that can provide some
funding for that unfortunately the cap
for that is a 150 thousand dollars with
a one-to-one match we do have a
conservation program where institutions
museums again can apply to do
conservation work if it's a priority
within their institution and that
certainly includes all the digital
activities that we've been talking about
the keep project and the products i
talked about in the beginning here all
came from our national leadership grant
program both museums and libraries are
eligible for this program in total
there's a round 21 22 million dollars
available for this program both museums
and libraries eligible and this is the
key program also that institutes of a
higher education are eligible to apply
for and receive funding grants in this
program are up to 1 million dollars
generally if your request is over
250,000 there's a one-to-one match
except for research projects we don't
require much so all that's a little
complicated i won't get into that right
now read as you can see on the screen
there are four particular categories and
certainly many of the projects we've
talked about here can apply to multiple
categories building digital resources
isn't so much putting stuff online or
creating the resources that sort of all
right I have all this stuff up I have
all this stuff available what do I do
with it how can I make best use of it
and that's where this partnerships and
these other activities come on for
example the George Mason project I
talked about and the big announcing
project in Michigan State are all
building digital resource categories so
I already have this stuff but they're
trying to find better ways that people
can access it and have more uses for
more types of people in the third
category research and demonstration
necessarily wanted a key categories
where we could see some of these
partnerships of where for example the
center here Columbia is interested in
some of the preservation some of the
collaborations you can partner with
libraries and partner with museums see
how you can get some commonalities for
preservation activities or the
interoperability of different systems
can come together and we've just started
this first year collaborative planning
grants since these are million-dollar
grants often times or multiple hundreds
of thousands sometimes you need some
resources to put together competitive
application to do some of the basic work
of assessing the need and determining
what the national impact is so we do
have collaborative planning grants and
most for our four thirty thousand
dollars and now I'm running through this
quick but I'm just want these to get
this all in the back of your mind and
hopefully you'll come back and look at
you have an idea library I provide a
list of programs here let me go back to
the state library agencies part of the
funding at IMLS is block grants to the
states to the state library agencies and
then each state gets an X amount of
dollars primarily based on population
through a formula funding in the State
Library Association's make determination
how that money goes out but may in the
State Library Association's do areas in
preservation to areas in video do areas
in partnership for the library so again
it's another opportunity to think of
when you're thinking of projects and
want to partner with other people that
this is an opportunity to receive some
funding we go through grants.gov just
like in the HTS I need to remind you of
that particular procedure which can be
entertaining at times one thing we are
our director is particularly interested
in conservation the primary focus is
objects at this point but certainly the
born digital has a key in that first
bullet I want to remind people to go to
heritage preservation we funded I think
with any agent and he also provided the
heritage heritage health index which
talked about some of the dire straits
some of our collections are in in that
digital activities were certainly
included in that and so in response to
that I MLS's is doing a connecting two
collections a call to action we're
having a summit at the end of June the
invitees have already been determined
we're inviting museum and library
personnel and funding them to come to
representatives from each state as well
as particular scholars and advocates in
those particular field but the important
thing is we're also doing for regional
forums across the country within the
next two years after that that will
touch on a variety of topics that will
be one in response to the issues that
come up at the forum at the initial
National Conservation summit then also
be regionally directed topics that are
relevant to those particular areas so
again there's an area where we certainly
expect certainly at the regional summits
regional forums to talk more about the
preservation of digital activities and
we're also going to provide statewide
planning grants so individual states can
do some planning for activities they'd
like to do in the conservation area so
again that's all these you hear a lot
about the content
created at this meeting of all the great
media which being developed but at one
point there's a little touch on well we
have sort of the two inch tapes we have
the dvds what's it going to be next and
how do we save it and how do we then it
all it gets back to access how's
everybody in an access this information
maybe next year two years from now or
how do you get through that information
from three or four years ago I think we
heard about it in the both the public
broadcasting archive projects and
certainly the British archive projects
of accessing that old technologies
between the best word but that's more
difficult the other thing I want to call
your attention to is a free conference
it's actually very much like this we
call it web lives where museums and
libraries come together and a lot of its
best practices we have sessions where
you hear what's going on here what
projects are going and we also try and
have some key speakers to talk about
what's going on in the digital
technology worlds of both museums and
libraries it's a free conference it's a
first-come first-serve that the 350
people this year we filled it in two
weeks it is generally held in into
februari early March this one it was in
DC this past year next year it will be
out of DC we are currently have an RFP
out to fill that but keep track of that
I think many of you would find that very
interesting which leaves me how do you
keep track of stuff at IMLS one way is
we have an email newsletter called
primary source comes out monthly tracks
our grant programs highlights projects
highlights issues that I MLS that we're
touching on and also informs you of
conferences and the like I have my
contact information I have my web
address their back at the table right
where your guards I have a cut of where
you got your badges and folders I have a
copy of the slides if you want to pick
those up there's a little brochure about
our 2008 programs if you tired of trying
to look stuff up you can have this the
printed versions and our website is very
easy IMLS gov thank you very much